-Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, this Sunday is
the 94th Academy Awards.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, the Oscars are 94,
and typical Hollywood, they're
all dating statues in their 20s.
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait.
The biggest stars
walking the red carpet,
being asked "Who are you
wearing? Who swabbed you?"
You know.
[ Laughter ]
Quick heads-up, if you hear
a piercing shriek
halfway through the show,
that's just me
when Questlove wins the Oscar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, Quest, you're
going to enjoy this, all right?
So, the Oscar gift bag this year
has a value of $140,000.
[ Audience oohs ]
$140,000.
Can we see what's in the bag?
Oh, it's gas. Oh, fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
It's a gallon of gas.
-Wow.
-A gallon -- a whole gallon.
The big nominees this year
are "The Power of the Dog,"
"CODA," "Belfast," and a bunch
of others you started streaming
and forgot to finish.
[ Laughter ]
But this is new.
I saw that this year,
there's a Fan Favorite Award
that will be decided
by a vote on Twitter.
That's why the Oscar will go
to a TikTok
of a guy falling
off a golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this year, the Oscars
are paying tribute
to "The Godfather"
for its 50th anniversary.
They'll be like -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, they're like,
"We're here to honor
all the great 'Godfather' movies
--
'The Godfather,'
'Godfather: Part II.'
You know, those two movies."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the Oscars will also pay tribute
to the James Bond franchise.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It makes sense because there are
just so many classic Bond films.
I mean, here,
check out this promo
that The Academy just released.
-This year, The Academy
is excited to take a look back
at every James Bond film,
including...
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Blue, da ba dee, da ba die ♪
-...and of course...
-There you go. Excellent.
A lot of great classics.
-Wow. Classic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Wow.
-Speaking of movies,
everyone is talking about this.
The director of "The Batman"
just released a deleted scene
showing Robert Pattinson
facing off against The Joker.
-Ooh.
-It's pretty shocking.
I had no idea that you could
release a three-hour movie
and still have deleted scenes.
[ Laughter ]
Impossible.
But the scene
is really something.
I mean, we haven't seen
a Batman face off
against The Joker in months.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news.
Today, the second season
of "Bridgerton"
started streaming on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
Mother's Day came early
this year.
Yeah, that's right.
-Oh, oi.
-At least I -- Apparently,
a lot of the fans were upset
'cause this season
has way fewer sex scenes.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
"Bridgerton"
without the sex scenes,
which explains this new
Netflix message I saw.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Isn't that weird?
Got even weirder when Netflix
added more sex scenes
to "Is It Cake?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
-Did you guys --
Did you guys see this?
North Korea just released
a hype video
for its most recent
missile launch.
Take a look --
Take a look at this. It's real.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-That's real.
-No.
-Yeah.
-Y'all did that.
-No, that's real, man.
That's actually real, yeah.
-No, this is the part where --
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, no, yeah.
No, nothing says
that you're in charge
like pointing at something
in slow motion.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Dance.
-At a certain point,
everyone was just like,
"Is your watch broken?
What's going on?"
With everything Putin's doing,
this is Kim Jong-Un's way
of saying,
"Hey, I'm nuts, too.
Remember me?
Remember me, guys? Come on."
But on the bright side,
Kim Jong-Un was just nominated
for an Oscar --
Best Dictator Short.
-Oh. Nice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is nice.
Today, President Biden was
in Poland visiting our troops
and even stayed for some pizza.
But I think the jalapeño slice
caught him by surprise.
Watch -- Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-You -- [ Laughs ]
You know it must have been bad
when during a pandemic,
Biden is like,
"Let me drink from your cup.
Let me --
I need something to --
Hand it over.
Just -- Just spit it
in my mouth.
Just go -- I really --
I don't --
Hot, hot, hot."
Yeah, the spice
really got to him.
And this is real.
He was still feeling it
a little later.
This is a real video.
Check it out.
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I love that dude.
I love how he says "pizza pie."
I don't even think
Mario and Luigi say that.
[ Laughter ]
It was like,
"You know what gives me
worse heartburn that pizza pie?
Pas-- Pasketti."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
IHOP and Pepsi have teamed up to
create the new maple syrup cola.
Here it is.
Yeah.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah, I'm trying to be healthy,
so I'm going to wait
'til they come out
with a diet maple syrup Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it turns out
the executives at IHOP
are just as drunk
as the customers.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a new study
found that drinking two
to three cups of coffee a day
could add years to your life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
On the flip side, if you want
to take years off of your life,
try the new maple syrup Pepsi
from IHOP.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots.
Go. Come on.
[ Tariq rapping indistinctly ]
♪♪
-What a show we have
for you tonight.
I'm so excited.
They are the hosts
of "Desus & Mero,"
which airs Thursday nights
at 11:00 on Showtime.
Desus and Mero are here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Funny -- Funny dudes.
Plus, she's amazing.
She's a Grammy-winning artist
whose new album "Humble Quest"
is out now.
Maren Morris is here tonight.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's just out today.
-Oh!
-This -- The album is out today.
"Humble Quest."
We're going to talk to Maren,
and then she's going to perform
for us tonight on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, I'm very excited
about this.
Next Tuesday, I have a new
children's book coming out
[ Cheering and applause ]
called...
This is a goodie.
-Tear-jerker.
-This is -- Yeah.
"More than Paris
and the Eiffel Tower?
More than cats
with SUPER cat powers."
[ Awws, laughter, and applause ]
Anyway, it's -- Yeah.
Don't cry yet, Higgins.
But it is a little bit
of a weeper.
-Yeah.
-Sweet.
-But, to celebrate,
all next week,
we're going to be showcasing
some very talented grandmas
on the show,
from all over the country.
Musicians, dancers, comedians,
lots more.
So look for that
every night next week.
It's going to be fun.
Nana Week!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nana.